Lisa you took part today in a session on
do we really need fiber very interested
to hear your comments on that but before
we start turns a little bit about it now
yes no are the big European telco
operators and well most of them are
incumbents but there are also acts as
seekers in the other European countries
so a lot of people view at know as being
this conservative incumbent organization
but we're actually an organization that
has a broader view and needs to have
consensus views on on many issues in
urinal it's very interesting and what
were some of those views you expressed
today well actually one some of a very
important viewers actually that
competition is good competition is is a
good as a driver for investment and
infrastructure competition is very
important for us consumer demand is
another part of it and these are
actually two factors that are not a part
of the framework we have today but for
us it's really important that you have
this infrastructure competition in order
to achieve many of the things we'd like
to do we have 5g we have internet of
things we have a growing demand and
actually to to come and fulfill that
demand it's absolutely important that we
have more investment and we need
regulation to help us with this and how
would we achieve that you know what's
your watch your vision to achieving that
actually a regulation as it is today has
done a great job of creating competition
but now we see that regulation is not
promoting investment good enough so we
need to have a look at the framework as
it is today and we know the Commission
is doing that we need to have a
regulation that's more future oriented
we need a regulation that
more seeking to look at innovation and
to actually have a certainty of the
investment market because what we see is
that there is an investment gap of a
hundred and six billion euros in order
to reach the goals that we have set for
2020 regarding broadband so we need to
have a regulation that can help us
enhance this and also enhance innovation
as such that's that's quite a gap isn't
it it is but do you do you remain
confident are you confident that we're
going to get there because as you said
yourself there's things like the
Internet of Things 5g all coming down
the pipe at the moment actually we're
very confident that we can reach this
with a framework review we know that the
Commission has focus on this and I find
that very positive and I think the
review gives us a great opportunity to
the industry and the Commission together
to have a look and actually see what
what ways we can work with the
regulation in order to ensure areas
where you don't have competition but
where you have competition you could
roll the regulation back and actually
buy this give better room for investment
they should thanks very much for joining
us thank you so a confident message for
the future from it know who represent
some of the leading telcos right across
Europe